dass die ehre des westens am hindukusch
verteidigt worden ist wird niemand
behaupten ordnungs mächte und
rechtsstaats privater sind bloß gestellt
worden und das in einem ausmaß dass ich
vor kurzem noch niemand vorstellen
konnte wer davon scherbenhaufen spricht
untertreibt glatt abzug aus afghanistan
politik sagen globales politikversagen
jetzt an der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
wir alle zusammen die wir in afghanistan
engagiert war also die gesamte
internationale koalition
wir alle haben die geschwindigkeit
dieser entwicklung ganz offensichtlich
unterschätzt das gilt auch für
deutschland
mit dieser feststellung der
bundeskanzlerin beginnt allerdings erst
die auf verwaltung und endet nicht und
damit herzlich willkommen bei uns meine
gäste zunächst hier im studio sonja
zekri sie ist redakteurin und berlin
korrespondentin der süddeutschen zeitung
reinhard iro es ist bei uns oberst der
bundeswehr
außer diensten und gründer der
kinderhilfe afghanistan sie sind seit 98
in diesem land unterwegs das war noch
zur zeit der ersten taliban-herrschaft
mit humanitärer hilfe im osten des
landes sie waren aber auch schon zu
zeiten der sowjetischen besatzung in den
1980 er jahren dort
humanitären aktiv zugeschaltet ist der
vorsitzende des bundeswehrverbandes
andré wüstner und endlose der leiter der
parlamentsredaktion der frankfurter
allgemeinen zeitung hier in berlin
wüstner sind denn die
evakuierungsflüge die die bundeswehr
immer noch durchführt in dieser woche
durchführen will noch sicher oder spitzt
sich nach ihrer information die lage in
kabul weiter zu
naja die lage spitzt sich weiter zu zum
einen gibt es erkenntnisse dass es
natürlich menschen unterschiedliche
interessengruppen es gibt ja neben den
taliban auch terroristische
organisationen dass man gegebenenfalls
mit attentaten zu rechnen hat das ist
das eine und zum zweiten nach der
information nach der aussage von
außenminister maß dass man nicht mehr
alle retten werden können das dann
natürlich noch mal der druck sich erhöht
von menschen aus afghanistan in richtung
kabul und das ist eine brandgefährliche
situation man ist unter druck und muss
jetzt sehen wie man koordiniert
sozusagen den ausflug denn das
zeitfenster schließt sich ja aktuell und
eine schlinge um den flughafen zieht
sich zu das ist eine besondere situation
und damit muss man jetzt umgehen dazu
passt ja auch eine meldung eine aktuelle
des deutschen botschafters in
afghanistan markus poetzel der im moment
in doha den
staat katar am persischen golf mit den
taliban verhandelt dass die paar jahren
kann die man angeblich zugesagt haben
dass auch nach dem 31 acht noch
ausreisen aus afghanistan für
afghaninnen und afghanen möglich sind
sofern sie gültige dokumente vorweisen
können was immer das heißt frau sigrid
haben wir uns eigentlich zu wenig mühe
gemacht afghanistan und die afghanen zu
verstehen
ich denke dass diejenigen die da gewesen
sind sich schon sehr große mühe gegeben
haben also dass wir jetzt ein schlag ins
gesicht aller leute die da unten
entweder mit der bundeswehr waren oder
auch mit
entwicklungshilfeorganisation die werden
sich schon große mühe gegeben haben ich
bin nicht sicher wie viel davon in der
deutschen öffentlichkeit angekommen ist
dabei das interesse ja zum teil sehr
überschaubar und man fragt sich wie viel
tatsächlich dann auch in der politik
angekommen ist zumindest was den
vormarsch der taliban angehen
jetzt sagt man ja es war jetzt 20 jahre
vergeblich gewesen was man da gemacht
hat war wirklich alles vergeblich in
afghanistan kurz dann haben sie das wort
umsonst nicht benutzt soll angeblich
also umsonst war sicher nicht das war
ein teurer einsatz müssen wir alle an
sondern über eine billion us dollar
million us dollar teuerste griechen der
geschichte der menschheit viele viele
opfer auf seiten des westens auch bei
meinen kameraden
90 tote verladen und bei der
afghanischen bevölkerung da wissen wir
gar nicht wieviel 10.000 oder
hunderttausend zu tode gekommen sind
also unter dem aspekt aufwand und nutzen
oder aufwand und ergebnis war es ein
vergeblicher einsatz der uns zu denken
geben sollen und falls man so was mal
wieder vorhaben also wir nicht 4 3 aber
die politik sollte man sich das genau
überlegen und eine strategien einüben
einsetzen bevor man an so etwas denkt
hat lohse der katzenjammer der deutschen
politik ist jetzt groß ist außer bei
denen die das schon immer so haben
kommen sehen ist das ein kollektives
versagen der regierung mit ansage
also ich bin bei dem wort versagen immer
etwas vorsichtig und trotzdem dass die
kanzlerin heute gesagt hat hinterher
sind immer alle schlauer finde ich dann
schon reichlich
lapidar wie sie es gesagt hat es gab
sehr viele anzeichen
spätestens seit der tramp gesagt hat die
amerikaner gehen raus aus afghanistan
aber eigentlich auch schon vorher war ja
klar dass das ein hoher gefährdungen für
die ortskräfte gibt es gibt seit langem
eine regelung für ortskräfte also dass
das gerade in diesem jahr mit dem abzug
dann dramatisch werden würde das war
klar dann müssen wir natürlich daran
denken wir sehen in dem wahlkampf jahr
und da gab es schon auch innenpolitische
bremsen sage ich mal die verhindert
haben dass man vielleicht alle
informationen die man hatte auch
sachgerecht rechtzeitig in handeln
umgesetzt
sie haben jetzt dankenswerterweise
gerade diese äußerungen der
bundeskanzlerin von heute mittag erwähnt
hier schauen uns die noch mal an in
voller länge sind allerdings nur drei
sätze liebe zuschauer dass die kanzlerin
ja auch so etwas wie ja war das eine
rechtfertigung war das ablenkung vom
thema wir schon zusammen
hinterher im nachhinein präzise analysen
und bewertungen zu machen das ist nicht
wirklich kompliziert
hinterher im nachhinein alles genau zu
wissen und exakt vorherzusehen das ist
relativ mühelos ja also wir wehren uns
trotzdem weiterhin mühe geben beim thema
afghanistan auch in dieser sendung und
sicherlich werden auch die analysen auch
in dieser sendung aber die auch in
nächster zeit sicherlich auch ziemlich
kompliziert werden frau zypries der soll
jetzt in deutschland zur rechenschaft
gezogen werden für das wer hat die
politische verantwortung
ich bin kein politiker ich bin auch kein
kein richter rechenschaft ziehen oder
polizist ich blicke auch zu wenig zürich
wie das gelaufen ist in den ministerien
zwischen den ministerien zwischen den
bundesnachrichtendienst und den
informationen auch von seiten der
bundeswehr an die politik da ich das
nicht weiß wer wann was gewusst und
nicht weitergegeben oder wie auch immer
sich widersprochen wird werde ich mich
enthalten weil ihre frage wer ist jetzt
der schuld ja schon hingerichtet werden
gut es geht ja nicht mehr hinrichtungen
sondern es geht darum wer die
verantwortung übernimmt so könnten uns
auch ausdrücken die zwei minister haben
es schon getan oder eine ministerin ein
minister frau kam karrenbauer hat gesagt
ich halte meinen kopf hin und herr maas
hat es auch gesagt und das sind
natürlich die
deren handel man sich anschauen muss im
nachhinein andererseits würde ich
natürlich auch sagen dass die art und
weise wie herr seehofer
schon sehr früh hat durchblicken lassen
dass das ihnen das entweder gar nicht
interessiert oder das ist dann doch eben
schon sehr früh nur um flüchtlinge geht
das klang jetzt auch nicht gerade danach
als ob sich da jemand ein bein ausreißen
um möglichst einfache bedingungen für
diejenigen zu schaffen die aus
afghanistan raus müssen wir wissen da
sind die bundeswehr soldatinnen und
soldaten die sie ja vertreten sind die
zufrieden mit der bisherigen reaktion
der politik
nein auf keinen fall und ich muss
zugestehen dass ich auch die heutige
regierungserklärung erst noch verdauen
muss insbesondere im letzten teil als
die kanzlerin eine menge an fragen
aufgeworfen hat wo ich ehrlich gesagt
dachte dass man sich diese fragen schon
letzten jahren gestellt hat und versucht
hat antworten zu geben und ich denke die
aktuelle situation die treibt alle um
gar nicht mal so sehr den schnellen
vormarsch der taliban damit haben viele
seit jahren gerechnet da wurde auch
schon viel beschrieben selbst inzwischen
berichten der bundesregierung als an das
parlament wissenschaft haben darauf hat
darauf hingewiesen fachleute haben
darauf hingewiesen der punkt ist er der
was aktuell aufregt ist der umgang die
kommunikation und das was wir mit den
orts kräften erleben diese
fehleinschätzung der umgang das
sozusagen konzeptlose seit april das ist
sozusagen das was wir jetzt unter dem
brennglas erkennen was diesen
gescheiterten vernetzten ansatz betrifft
und das sind klein ist die ursache für
das scheitern im großen dieses nicht
diese nicht vorhandene strategie
fähigkeit diese nicht vorhandene
einschätzung der lage des kulturkreises
der region und dann natürlich auch das
ziel definieren die ziele zu in ihren
die unrealistische und wo wir auch nur
begrenzte ressourcen dafür haben das
wird jetzt alles an die oberfläche
transportiert und das treibt viele
menschen in den streitkräften um kommen
gleich darauf noch einmal zurück
klose jetzt noch mal bei dieser
regierungserklärung oder debatte im
bundestag bleiben von heute mittag
es werden ja immer wieder rücktritte
gefordert von alpha einzelne personen
von einzelnen personen
untersuchungsausschuss für nötig
gehalten wie sollte die politik jetzt in
grießen management reagieren sind diese
forderungen nach rücktritt oder nach
untersuchungsausschuss nebelkerzen oder
wie versucht man jetzt oder wie kann
sich die politik da ja
rechtfertigen zeigt sie einsicht wie
soll sie welche lehren soll sie aus
diesem desaster ziehen
also ich glaube um lehren zu ziehen
reichen rücktritt der
rücktrittsforderungen gar nichts wir
haben in wenigen wochen der
bundestagswahl da kommen sowieso ein
paar der verantwortlich handelnden gar
nicht mehr infrage haus seefahrt schon
gesagt dass er das der politik
ausscheidet also das ist natürlich jetzt
wohlfeil und führt ja auch wirklich
nicht weiter außer im taktischen
klein-klein die entscheidende frage ist
natürlich haben wir uns gerade in
deutschland zu lange ein trugbild
gemacht davon was alles möglich ist in
afghanistan dieser einsatz konnte hier
in dem krieg skeptischen und militär
skeptischen land was ja eher militär
skeptischer wird als zugewandter konnte
ja immer nur begründet werden verkauft
werden muss man etwas platz zu sagen
indem man sagt in einer in erster linie
machen wir der nation building wir
helfen diesem staat wir helfen im
bildungssystem in bei den
menschenrechten usw das kennen wir alles
die klarheit mit der zum beispiel ein
präsident beiden jetzt sagt das war
immer nur ein terror einsatz wären wir
nie gewollt und jetzt reicht's auch mal
die klingt jetzt wie und da mal an in
deutschland ist aber natürlich in den
letzten jahren oder jahrzehnten
ausgeblieben also wir haben uns zur
richtigen ehrlichen sich offenbar auf
teile der afghanischen wirklichkeit hat
sich die politik hier nicht getraut es
gab genug menschen die das wussten
wahrscheinlich viele soldaten die in dem
land waren entwicklungshelfer usw usw
die wussten das schon besser vielleicht
sogar der geheimdienst der bnd und
anderer geheimdienste aber man hat sich
hier immer ein bisschen ein schleier vor
die augen gehalten glaube ich weil man
gar nicht sagen wollte was dieser
einsatz eigentlich leisten kann und was
er nicht leisten kann wir wissen dass
gerade die strategischen defizite
benannt dieses afghanistan-einsatzes was
sind die ersten lehren die man ziehen
sollte aus diesem einsatz es kann ja
sein dass die bundeswehr in anderen
weltgegenden vielleicht sogar noch sehr
viel näher an europa auch demnächst
wieder für auslandseinsätze gebraucht
wird
ja es geht grundsätzlich um den begriff
strategie fähigkeit und der beginnt
natürlich mit einer ordentlichen
lageanalyse der analyse der region des
kulturkreises der frage der ethnien der
stämme beispielsweise der clans und
welche auswirkungen das hat ihm wie weit
man überhaupt mit einem zentralistischen
ansatz erfolge erzielen kann in einer
region wie afghanistan oder in der sahel
zone das sind dinge die man als erstes
machen muss und dann wenn ich zehn die
ziele definieren das ist ja in einem
wirtschaftsunternehmen gleichermaßen
dann musste ich mich vor weg um meine
ressourcen kümmern und auch gedanken
machen was tatsächlich erreichbar ist
und das ist dann ein realistisches ziel
bild das man angehen kann wenn man ziele
operationalisieren und da muss ich
ehrlich sagen da war die bundesregierung
den letzten jahren schwach und es ist
nicht so wie es teilweise erscheint dass
es da keine wissenschaft keine fachleute
gibt die darauf hingewiesen haben dass
wir probleme haben im kern war das ja
der grund warum wir auch alle viele auch
die opposition und ehrlich gesagt auch
viele koalitionspolitiker in den letzten
jahren evolution gefordert haben nicht
nur um zu sagen na ja wo stehen wir
aktuell sondern auch lehren zu ziehen
dann auch für andere einsätze denn
ehrlich gesagt wenn ich jetzt in leere
blicke oder auch in dieser zone da
werden wir vergleichbare sozusagen
falsche ziele falsche realitäten
wahrnehmen und deswegen muss eine
nächste bundesregierung auch diese
anderen einsätze überprüfen reflektieren
was tatsächlich erreichbar wir sind ja
einer strategie schwäche offenbar stehen
wir ja gegenüber dass es jetzt hier auch
gerade schon angeklungen wenn wir jetzt
noch einmal zusammenfasst was das seit
2001 in afghanistan passiert ist die usa
wollten sommer bin laden jagten und zur
rechenschaft ziehen wegen der an wegen
des angriffs waren eleven auf die
zwillingstürme in manhattan die
bundesrepublik und der damalige
bundeskanzler haben um eingeschränkte
solidarität geschworen sie mussten aber
von anfang an gleichzeitig hier in
deutschland diesen einsatz immer mit
humanitären argumenten rechtfertigen da
gab es dann solche begriffe wie
bewaffnete entwicklungshilfe wenn man
mit so unterschiedlichen ansätzen in ein
solches land geht kann das doch
eigentlich nur schiefgehen ist ja auch
schief gegangen also von anfang an
schiesser von anfang an hier
verantworten das ist ja dass die beiden
begriffe die oder dürften den kannst der
schüler dadurch ändert uneingeschränkte
solidarität wenige wochen nach dem
einlesen zu einem präsidenten bush den
mann damals eher etwas
sowie sozusagen schwach eingeschätzt hat
was aus und politische fähigkeiten der
fahrer angehen zudem sagen
uneingeschränkt das wird erst einmal
nachlesen das bedeutet egal was du
machst ich mache mit das würde ich nie
zu jemandem sagen auch so zu meiner frau
und bei der mafia gibt es das da gibt es
um geräte sowie den ansonst werden
erschossen das hat ein präsident ein
kanzler schröder zu beginn gesagt und
dann kommt der zweite
schlüsselsatz vom damaligen
verteidigungsminister jetzt verstorben
schlug nämlich die sicherheit
deutschlands wird auch am hindukusch
verteidigt
ich kannte den hindukusch kamen als
schon 2030 beiden 80 jahren sei es
anfang während der schwedischen gegen
vier jahre dort knüpfte dort habe als
arzt im krieg gegen die russen auf der
seite der paschtunen der mudschaheddin
versorgt musste also ungefähr was
afghanistan es zumindest was paschtunen
totale wahnsinn ein paar stunden und
wenn da einer jetzt sagt die paar
stunden
der hindukusch ist eine bedrohung für
uns da habe ich mich schon ich sage es
mal freundlich war damals noch aktive
offiziere der bundeswehr habe ich mich
schon etwas gewundert und bin daraufhin
aus der bundeswehr vorzeitig
ausgeschieden und für seite in meinem
eigenen krieg auch ein paar stunden
gebiet mit den taliban zusammen oder mit
taliban artikel mal weg weil das fast
alles passt und sind in einer gegend wo
sie entstanden sind und das glaubt seit
20 jahren wunderbar weil wir eine
strategie hatte strategie müssen als
vorher noch mal angesprochen muss man
auch mal die finger strategie ist da
gibt es ja auch keine sein konzept
überlegung strategie ist nach klausel
den großen deutschen filmmuseum mit
einer strategie ist die beschreibung
einer alle lebensbereiche umfassenden
vorgehensweise zur erreichung vorher
genau definierter ziele nichts davon hat
die deutsche und internationale politik
in afghanistan machen gar nicht alle
lebensbereiche eingeschlossen und sogar
nicht ziele genau definiert und wenn ich
so weder militärisch noch zivilem aufbau
wenn ich so rangehen als mächtigste
militärbündnis der welt unter führung
der mächtigste militärmacht der welt mit
deutscher hilfe die in afghanistan die
höchste reputation hat kein land der
welt hatte beim einmarsch jetzt hat sich
ein bisschen verschoben sage ich mal ein
so hohes ansehen in afghanistan wie wir
deutschen weil wir dort seinen 50er
jahren wie keine andere nation auch aus
der sicht der afghanen uneigennützige
hilfe geleistet haben entwicklungshelfer
wälder wieder auf gefragt deshalb war
das sind alles dinge die haben wir
entweder nicht gewusst 2000 einzeln in
berlin welche welches ansehen wir haben
wir hätten uns vielmehr einbringen das
in der überlegung der in den überlegung
der nato also gut gemeint ist noch lange
nicht gut gemacht frau ziegel sind ja
eine profunde kennerin der gegend am
anfang ging es um terroristenjagd die
wurden dann auch endlich schnell besiegt
die al kaida gruppierungen die da in
afghanistan unterschlupf gefunden haben
es ging ja zunächst mal um die jagd auf
diese terroristen nicht so sehr um den
sogenannten regime change in afghanistan
das kann man eben später erst dazu gibt
es eigentlich in diesen jahren zwischen
2001 und
2021 irgendeinen punkt wo der westen
irgendwie falsch abgebogen ist in seiner
afghanistan-strategie wo sozusagen der
ursprüngliche die ursprünglichen
absichten ja
die hat fallen lassen oder vielleicht
sogar verraten hat einen solchen punkt
ich glaube dass man sich von anfang an
nicht ganz ehrlich gegenüber war was die
ziele an also wir haben es jetzt ist
klar jetzt schon bei einigen
bei dem an was die herren gesagt da man
man ist da reingegangen es ging darum
der twin towers sind getroffen worden
der westen ist ins herz getroffen worden
und wir sind auch getroffen worden und
selbstverständlich war es 2001 so dass
wir das auch sehr viele haben das
persönlich genommen alle sind mal in new
york gewesen jetzt ist bei der
zwanzigste jahrestag von nine eleven und
natürlich hatte man den eindruck man
muss etwas tun
gemeint sind wir damals in unsere
wertegemeinschaft der westen und dieses
die sicherheit wird am hindukusch
verteidigt
da wäre ich natürlich ganz bei ihnen und
würde sagen das ist eine frage die
taliban war
bedeutete die taliban waren janni
expansiv die waren ja nicht also ob sie
es jetzt mal werden muss man sehen aber
sie waren es eben damals nicht aber es
war eben schon etwas was dann sozusagen
in so einen in so eine wertedebatte die
dann die idee wurde aber dann auch
letztlich nicht wirklich benannt und im
grunde genommen ging es auch neben
vielem anderen wie korruption und man
hat auch falsche politiker gesetzt und
wahlen anerkannt die man nicht hätte
anerkennen sollen in afghanistan aber ja
es ging schon auch darum dass man diesen
einsatz
sozusagen dann verbringt hat mit diesen
frauenrechten und mit diesen mit diesem
wir bringen ihnen den afghanen jetzt die
demokratie
was ich eben jetzt als etwas
herausgestellt hat was wir eben dann
einfach doch nicht tun hallo so als
würde man nach 20 jahren nicht einfach
sagen wir haben es probiert es geht
nicht mehr klarkommt lose sie haben ja
die zeit 2001 auch schon als politischer
journalist erlebt diese äußerung von
gerhard schröder dieser
uneingeschränkten solidarität
kann es sein dass ein
verteidigungsminister der ja auch aus
der spd war peter struck diese
äußerungen dass eben die besten und
deutschland auch am hindukusch
verteidigt werden dass das eigentlich
eher von einer art notbehelf warum diese
äußerung von gerhard schröder mit der
sich der bundeskanzler ja sehr weit aus
dem fenster gehängt hat sozusagen
bisschen zu aktivieren oder wieder
einzuholen oder im nachhinein auch zu
rechtfertigen
naja natürlich man brauchte permanent
begründung für diesen ungeliebten
einsatz ist der kosovo krieg war ja noch
nicht lange her diese rot-grüne
regierung die wahl angetreten stolperte
in den ersten krieg und stand kurz vor
ihrer wiederwahl und stolperte in den
zweiten krieg rein schröder hat das ja
übrigens an abend des 11 septembers 2001
gesagt mit der uneingeschränkten
solidarität ich glaube unter dem schock
unter dem speck in dem gefühl du musst
jetzt sofort jegliche zweifel beseitigen
des vier deutsche die wir ja immer als
wenig militär affinen gehalten irgendwie
zucken deswegen dieser überzogene satz
den haben die grünen schon relativiert
die damals mit in der regierung waren
haben gesagt ja aber keine abenteuer und
das war natürlich ein versuch von struck
zu sagen das hilft auch uns wenn wir da
jetzt rein gehen und dann die ganze
verkleidung dieses einsatzes nation
building frauenrechte und so weiter das
ganze war eine regierung wie er fast
gescheitert wäre einmal fast zerfallen
wäre über eine einsatz entscheidung
gehabt schröder die die grünen rund um
christian ströbele in
vier-augen-gesprächen bearbeiten müssen
also dieser einsatz war gerade in der
frühphase politisch immer wahnsinnig
anstrengend und insofern hat man von
anfang an ihnen nicht wirklich sauberen
offen begründeten hatten gesagt
vielleicht auch von anderen seiten aus
wenn wir osama bin laden haben dann
können wir wieder gehen mehr wollen wir
da nicht so wie heute joe biden redet ja
dann wären wir natürlich längst raus
gewesen und die die es hat immer an
klarheit und wahrheit über die
begründung dieses einsatzes
gemangelt bis zum schluss als mann
gesagt hätten wenn wir mit der
bundeswehr rausgehen oder die soldaten
raus gehen um nicht das land sozusagen
allein zu lassen lassen wir diplomaten
und entwicklungshelfer noch drin heute
wissen wir dass es umgekehrt richtig
gewesen wäre da muss man sagen ja das
war natürlich alles ein gut gemeinter
ansatz zu sagen lasst das land nicht
sofort ganz alleine da hätte man sich
natürlich gewünscht dass die
sicherheitseinschätzung so ernst
genommen worden wären von den diensten
unserem oder auch anderen anderer länder
dass man sagt das ist eine schlechte
idee ist so rum zu drehen wir sehen uns
ja jetzt jetzt müssen wir wieder
reingehen mit einem teil der truppe und
haben diese entsetzlichen bilder und
dieses entsetzliche versagen diese
uneingeschränkte solidarität mit den usa
die haben die amerikaner offenbar nicht
sehr beeindruckt sie haben gerade schon
angesprochen
der ja nicht daran denkt seine
bündnispartner und vorher zu
konsolidieren wenn er seine afghanistan
strategie in dem fall diese sogenannte
exit-strategie das verlassen des landes
ändert was hat das eigentlich über das
transatlantische bündnis aus
erstmal müssen wir zum alten grundsatz
zurück auf cortex ist local joe biden
hat natürlich ein problem mit der enorm
starken samt wählerschaft die immer noch
präsent ist er versucht jetzt auch im
mittel westen in den sogenannten
spöttisch gesagt fly over countries
sympathien zu bekommen da wo sehr viele
soldaten herkommen den will er sagen so
ich bringe eure väter brüder söhne
wieder mit nach hause
das ist sein innenpolitisches motiv
warum das jetzt so hals über kopf geht
und so schnell geht und so rücksichtslos
eben auch da denkt er sicherlich nicht
an das was die deutschen mal gemacht
haben oder was versprochen haben oder
dass wir zweitgrößter truppensteller
waren das interessiert ihn in diesem
moment mal gerade gar nicht der denkt er
an die midterm elections im nächsten
jahr als an die deutsche innenpolitik
erst dann wenn wir schon beim thema
empathie für andere sind die halme die
bundeswehr soldaten die jetzt aus
afghanistan zurückgekehrt sind in den
letzten monaten vom einsatz noch dazu
sagen sie waren ja selbst einmal als
kompaniechef in afghanistan unterwegs
gewesen wir haben die bundeswehr
bundeswehrsoldaten der letzten monate
die aus afghanistan zurückgekommen sind
eigentlich das empfunden es war keine
kanzlerin keine verteidigungsministerin
zum empfang da dieser große
zapfenstreich den mann dann eilig
organisiert er kann jetzt aus
nachvollziehbaren gründen nicht
stattfinden im moment überhaupt doch
stattfindet wie ist das aufgenommen
worden in der truppe
naja aufgrund der breiten medialen
berichterstattung und zwar auch
einhellig dass man das sogar medial in
vielen kommentarspalten verurteilt hat
dass man so nicht mit einem einsatz der
bundeswehr abschließt ist es natürlich
klar dass nicht nur deshalb sondern auch
aus unmittelbaren empfinden eine große
enttäuschung und teilweise wut vorhanden
da vorhanden ist deswegen wird gerade
schon mit spannung darauf geachtet wie
man mit denjenigen umgeht spezialkräften
fallschirmjägern den sanitätern der
luftwaffe die jetzt gerade die kohlen
für die regierung aus dem feuer holen
und was das für die nächsten tage
bedeutet wut ist insgesamt vorhanden was
die politische kommunikation anbelangt
ich sage es noch mal nicht weil man
nicht erwartet hätte in den
streitkräften wie sich das bezogen auf
die taliban entwickelt sondern eher die
kommunikation der umgang mit den orts
kräften aber ich will noch einen
weiteren punkt machen möchte ein lose da
recht geben mit blick auf den beginn
dieses einsatzes da war halt der
schwerpunkt bündnissolidarität wir waren
alle emotional betroffen und
bündnissolidarität ist auch ein wert an
sich und zu beginn war ja diese einsatz
klar umrissen was im zeitlichen aspekt
anbelangt und was die ziele betrifft
stichwort al-kaida- da ging es ja gar
nicht um die taliban als ganzes nur auf
der zeitachse wurden diese ziele
verwässert es wurden scheint realitäten
aufgebaut und es gab unterschiedliche
weichenstellungen wo man weichen falsch
gestellt hat und der klassische vorwurf
heute ist natürlich das stimmt herreros
hatte das angesprochen dass wir nicht
tatsächlich aus deutschland heraus
versucht haben sicherheitspolitik
mitzugestalten für diese region uns
einzubringen sondern im endeffekt sind
wir im windschatten von den amerikanern
gesegelt oder gefahren wie auch immer
und und das ist etwas das man definitiv
aufarbeiten muss in all den
unterschiedlichen zeit phasen aber
nochmal ja gut ist da denn noch gibt es
sehr viel in den streitkräften tod trotz
tod und verwundung die sagen zumindest
haben wir für eine gewisse zeit in
bestimmten regionen menschen bessere
lebensverhältnisse verschafft ich war ja
selber nicht nur vor ort in schwierigen
phasen und auch im bergdorf mit der
compagnie menschen geholfen haben
nichtsdestotrotz die nachhaltigkeit die
haben wir schon immer in frage gestellt
und das kommt ja auch aktuell zum tragen
wir hatten ja schon über vergeblichkeit
gesprochen im einsatz jetzt sagt andré
wüstner zumindest vorübergehend bessere
lebensbedingungen
wird denn was in den 20 jahren da in
afghanistan sich entwickelt hat und da
auch militärischem schutz und
politischer unterstützung der nato
truppen für den das alles verloren gehen
oder wird da vielleicht sogar etwas in
die zukunft zu retten sein wird das
nicht eine rückkehr in die
vorhergehenden zustände werden nicht
ganz das aus afghanistan bescheinigung
ihrer karriere werde er weiter auch
weiterhin auf das spielt schon eine
rolle jetzt die zeitkarten kleinen
zurzeit weltweit in alle islamischen
ländern das sollten wir nicht
unterschätzen der ring jetzt immer so
über kleinigkeiten seit zwölf tagen
feiern die wie damals auch meinen eleven
nicht eine police talents anlage wo die
karten damals hoch gingen als die die
flugzeuge in die türme reingeflogen sind
jetzt feiern sie die niederlage die
bösen buben gesagt dass man so in den
islamischen ländern journalisten wollen
die feine 2 nach den ostereiern zusammen
die haben die größte militärmacht der
welt die amerikaner in erster linie
besiegt die haben dazu geführt dass die
aus einem kleinen bergland afghanistan
geschlagen abgezogen das ist noch gar
nicht so richtig bewusst welche
begeisterung das körper jungen moslems
meine ich jetzt die dschihadistische
moment weltweit in allen ländern wo der
islam mit 1,5 milliarden menschen
zur folge hat jetzt zu ihrer frage in
afghanistan ich bin jetzt so langsam
gesprochen seit über 20 jahren jetzt
dort also die halbe generation der
durchschnitt sogar die durchschnitts
afghani wird so 43 jahre alt und 20
jahre dort das heißt eine ganze
generation haben wir geprägt mit dem was
dort geschehen ist ich habe in diesen
21 habe ich es dort 30 schule gebaut
habe etwa ich war plötzlich gesetzt
waren und 80.000 mädchen vor gegenüber
mädchen schon gebaut und buben bis zum
abitur geführt ich studieren jetzt die
haben sich gependelt von mir gekriegt
wir haben die uni gebaut dort wo die
mädchen auch zu dienen können das gab es
vorher alles sein wird das erhalten
bleiben das war die frage das ist es
erstmal wenn ein mädchen 20 jahre so
aufgewachsen ist also mit abitur mit
einer guten schule mit erkenntnissen im
computer werden mit der guten bibliothek
mit der dauernden besuchen auch aus dem
westen über die medien inzwischen über
internet es gab es anfang ja auch nicht
dann hat das ja wahnsinnige wirkungen
jetzt nicht nur jetzt heute und die
letzten 20 jahre sondern auch für die
nächsten 20 jahre oder hoffentlich noch
länger solange diese mädchen leben jetzt
mitte werden ich stelle fest von den
mädchen die in afghanistan zur schule
gehen ich bin ja ich hab mich mal wieder
mit erziehungsminister telefoniert in
kabul und auch in jalalabad neben
gesundheitsminister von dem mädchen die
wir jetzt in der schule ausgebildet in
den schulen ausgebildet haben drei
provinzen im osten im unterschied zu
mädchen die nicht zur schule gegangen
sind die kriegen dort die mädchen ohne
schulbildung gegen sechs kinder pro frau
pro familie unsere 2,1 afghanistan ist
was die bedingte
fraktions wachstum angeht das im
negativen sinne dynamisch der folge auf
der welt die bevölkerung afghanistan hat
sich in den letzten 30 jahren
verdreifacht erst mal für deutschland
vor und das kann man sich mit bildung
mit anderen möglichkeit nach vorn mit
bildung gebildete frauen kriegen ich so
viele kinder weil sie wissen was das
bedeutet für die familie wenn ich selbst
kinder oder wenn ich zwei kinder habe
meine mädchen die oder sagte meine die
schule kann im schnitt 2,1 kinder die
mädchen aus den nachbardörfern muss
keine schule gab haben sechs kinder und
da spielt mit ganz ganz große rolle für
die zukunft des volkes auch neben vielen
anderen fan jetzt ist aber die frage ob
die diese demografische entwicklung
bestand hat es wird ja von einigen
gesagt also dieser 20-jährige einfluss
auch westliche vorstellungen im land er
hat die gesellschaft schon etwas
moderner gemacht in diesem land gilt das
nur für das urbane milieu in kabul und
in einigen größeren städten oder gilt
das allgemein so kann man können auch
die taliban nicht mehr wie früher
einfach so durch regieren sondern müssen
da auch rücksicht nehmen das wäre
natürlich der idealfall das wäre das was
wir uns wünschen würden das wäre das war
sozusagen was sich auch alle wünschen
auch in denen also ich bin hab' den
letzten tagen auch mit vielen
menschen gesprochen man ist ja dann
erstaunt wie viele menschen tatsächlich
in diesen 20 jahren kontakte mit
afghanistan hat und diejenigen die aus
der entwicklungszusammenarbeit kommen
die sagen dann
ich fühle ein tiefes gefühl der
beschämung und das was sie gesagt hat
was sie angesprochen haben diesen
fortschritt der ist natürlich
fantastisch für eines der ärmsten länder
der welt und
wenn sie sagen dass
viele muslime also die dschihadistische
muslime die sich angesprochen haben
jetzt die sektkorken knallen lassen ja
dann wird das so sein dass andere ist
natürlich und das darf man nicht
vergessen wenn wir uns sozusagen wieder
fragen warum radikalisiert sich da
irgendjemand in diesen ländern
was der westen oder wir auch deutschland
an diesen menschen begangen hat ist eine
20-jährige anstrengung was wir jetzt
begehen wird in den augen sehr vieler
menschen dort unten einfach als verrat
wahrgenommen es ist nicht der erste
vertrag den der westen an diesen ländern
verübt es gibt eine lange geschichte des
verrats im nahen osten es ist ein 1
mission 1 d stabilisieren und sich dann
zurückziehen wenn der preis zu hoch wird
und das heißt wenn wir jetzt sagen dass
die sozusagen die dschihadisten lassen
die sektkorken knallen dann lassen sie
auch die sektkorken knallen weil sie das
natürlich wissen weil die sozusagen
dieses versprechen das ist das was ich
gerade meinte wenn ich sage da sind
menschen in der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit die die
hingegangen sind die die frauen ermutigt
haben die sie sozusagen sagt dann macht
es traut euch wie alt jemand geworden
sogar gesagt wie take two step forward
denn wie dem cover der bäk und genau das
ist das was jetzt passiert diese jungen
mädchen ich hab ja auch am ich habe die
menschen anspricht mit dem auf sap die
journalistinnen das ist ja genau das was
jetzt passiert ja die werden kann
sicherheitsrisiko sein aber die stehen
da und haben gar nichts und wir haben
sie belassen wir holen unsere leute raus
und dann sagt im grunde genommen sagt
angela merkel sagt die deutsche
bundesregierung wir machen die tür zu
ist nicht gut gelaufen wir wählen jetzt
und dann werden die karten neu gemischt
und was das für geopolitische
auswirkungen später hat das können wir
uns jetzt überlegen und dann würde ich
keine prognose abgeben jedenfalls keine
grenzen wenn sie schon geopolitik
ansprechen ist dieser abzug auch etwas
verschiebt das auch die geopolitischen
gewichte gewaltig zu ungunsten des
westens also es ist auf jeden fall in
einer der westen hat hin nicht
wahnsinnig viel glaubwürdigkeit in der
gegend da sag ich ihnen nichts neues das
ist etwas was was sie gut wissen was
jeder weiß der da unten ist afghanistan
ist der fall gewesen wo man ja noch
dachte bei allem was schlecht ist bei
allem was auch geheuchelt ist bei allem
was auch möglicherweise eine art von
sozusagen von vorgeschobenen werte
universalismus ist es sind die
mädchenschulen gebaut worden es haben
frauen studiert die sterblichkeit ist
runtergegangen die kindersterblichkeit
die geburten sterblichkeit also sein
dass frauen im kindbett sterben das
alles ist geschehen es hat gute
parameter gegeben
und es war uns aber nicht wert dass wir
länger aushalten als bis zum jahrestag
von eingelaufen das ist das signal das
wir aussenden und wie das die werte der
wie das so zu sagen welche auswirkungen
das hat nebenan in pakistan in indien im
nahen osten jetzt wird schon davon
geredet dass es im irak möglicherweise
auch sozusagen ganz konkrete
auswirkungen haben wird ich glaube wir
sind wir stehen am anfang von etwas
zwischen den nicht am ende von etwas
nine eleven jahrestag elfter september
hat die rose das ist ja noch kurz vor
der bundestagswahl etwa 14 tage davor
die deutsche regierung auch deutet ja
immer auf die zeigt auf die amerikaner
sagt die haben sich aus dem staub
gemacht und jetzt mussten wir sozusagen
hinterher war das im interesse der
bundesregierung auch der interesse
deutschland jetzt so schnell aus
afghanistan abzuziehen oder wäre es
deutschland eigentlich lieber gewesen
dass noch ein bisschen zu verzögern also
jedenfalls nicht auf diese weise wie es
jetzt abgelaufen ist
ja also das ist manchmal gesetzt wenn
irgendjemand vorher diese bilder gehabt
hätte dann hätte man natürlich gesagt
das machen wir anders aber es gab ja
sogar bemühungen den einsatz zu
verlängern ich habe im märz im bundestag
das ist nicht gelungen das da stand
natürlich auch die amerikanische
entscheidung pate weil man sagt er das
trauen wir uns letztendlich nicht ohne
die amerikaner
militärisch noch drin zu bleiben hätte
aber nicht geklappt auch wenn wir der
zweitgrößte truppensteller waren aber
das also ist nicht ganz neu dass wir in
militärischen operationen von den
amerikanern abhängig sind aber es ist
selten mit so einer unglaublichen
klarheit vor augen geführt worden dass
wir wahrscheinlich sogar noch ein zwei
tage vor den amerikanern unsere
luftbrücke beenden werden weil wir
einfach nicht mal dass ohne sie können
also das ist natürlich alles nicht im
sinne der bundesregierung gewesen vor
allen dingen aber nicht eine debatte
darüber unmittelbar vor der wohnungswahl
also das wäre natürlich einfacher
gewesen zu sagen das wird noch ein
bisschen verlängert und dann machen wir
das alles nach der wahl aber die dynamik
kam in diesem fall dann eben so stark
aus washington dass es da keine
wirkliche möglichkeit mehr gegeben hat
gegenzuhalten wir wissen dass er gerade
aus ihren eigenen erfahrungen von ihren
eigenen erfahrungen erzählt als
kompaniechef in afghanistan die
bundeswehr nicht nur militärische
aufträge dort auch gehabt zumindest in
der anfangszeit auch kontakt zu
zivilbevölkerung ist da gesucht worden
das was ich jetzt erleben auch aus ihrer
persönlichen erfahrung mit afghanistan
ist das sind wir auf halbem weg stehen
geblieben wie sehr ist dieser rückschlag
auch jetzt also jetzt außerhalb der
militärischen überlegungen denn für die
bundeswehr da die groß ist dieser
rückschlag
naja also insgesamt ist es so dass die
streitkräfte natürlich professionell
sind und es gilt weiterhin das primat
der politik und bei jeglichen neuen
mandat wird man professionell sein
auftrag erfüllen aber natürlich gibt es
dennoch viele fragen fragen blick auf
die anderen einsatzgebiete und fragen
inwieweit fehleinschätzungen
gegebenfalls auch für andere
einsatzgebiete gelten also das ist schon
ein klarer punkt und was da stehen
geblieben anbelangt ich meine eins ist
klar in diesen tagen das ist enorm
bitter wenn man dazu hört wenn man das
wahrnimmt was da in afghanistan passiert
wir kennen unwahrscheinlich viele
menschen wir können die community der
entwicklungshilfe der stiftungen
derjenigen die eigenständig dort helfen
wenn man weiß was da passiert und sie
können sich vorstellen also nahezu
ständig auch am wochenende klingelt das
telefon das wird bei vielen von ihnen
gleichermaßen zu sein journalisten
abgeordnete familien aus deutschland die
noch verwandte in afghanistan haben die
für uns tätig waren rufen wir an bitten
um hilfe sind verzweifelt und all diese
gesamte menge lage ist natürlich so dass
die schon enttäuscht es beschämt
jemanden wie mich wie viele andere der
bundespräsident hat dieses wort genutzt
und dennoch muss man immer wieder den
blick nach vorne richten und für uns das
elementare dass dann eine neue regierung
sehr schnell reflektiert sehr schnell
überlegt sehr schnell strategie fähige
wird und mit blick auf die anderen
einsätze eben dafür sorgt dass man nicht
in gleicher art und weise vor die
nächste mauer läuft das ist für uns
elementar deswegen ja verbittert aber
auch ein blick nach vorn
das wort taliban führen viele im mund
aber viele wissen gar nicht so sehr was
ich dahinter eigentlich so wirkt es
waren sie ja schon seit der ersten
taliban-regimes in afghanistan unterwegs
sie kennen diese leute sie haben mit
denen verhandelt wie verhandelt man
eigentlich mit dem kann man mit denen
verhandeln worüber kann man mit den
vorhandenen mit wem verhandelt man
eigentlich kann man da deals machen das
ist ja jetzt auch wichtig für die frage
wie wir in zukunft mit diesem land
zumindest in humanitärer hinsicht
umgehen
ich stelle mir vor ein dreitägiges
wochenend seminar mit dem thema taliban
dann gar nicht gewusst was
übrigen also wir verhandeln ich auch
alle unsere projekte woche meinen 30
schulen für 70.000 kinder eine
universität für drei werken studenten
zwei große krankenhäuser berufs schulden
für schneiderin photovoltaik-anlagen usw
haben wir immer nur ausschließlich in
der absprache mit den dorfältesten
standards hält das um mit den taliban im
osten getroffen wenn die taliban gesagt
ich lasse jetzt mein artikel weg da gibt
es verschiedene
gute busen böse buben und weniger böse
buben wenn die gesagt haben nein
mädchenschule da hinten ist haben
brauchen wir nicht dann haben wir halt
nicht gebaut eineinhalb jahre später
kamen die bürgermeister lokale
lokalchefs haben sagt wir haben teile
ich mir jetzt noch eine also mit jedem
ob sie müssen die sprache können was
willst du vorhin angesprochen hat mit
regierung und zwar der kultur kompetent
sprachkompetenz und vertrauen wenn sie
alle halbe jahr als bundeswehr ihren
chef aus weg darum als entwicklungshilfe
alle drei viertel jahr ihren geschäften
auswechseln einer neuen bringen wenn die
alle die sprache nicht können ich kenne
kein bundeswehroffizier vielleicht gibt
es welche hoffentlich gibt es welche die
spargel passt du kannst die sprache die
mehrheit sprach in afghanistan die
sprache der taliban wenn sie die nicht
können und sie kinder hin dann sind sie
blind taub und stumm dann brauchen sie
einheimischen dolmetscher der tollpatsch
in afghanistan hat ein anderes
selbstverständnis als ein dolmetscher in
berlin das sind alles kleinigkeiten her
gerne die ihm die wir gar nicht
diskutieren aber die zeit nicht reicht
aber in die alle nicht funktionieren
dann geht das voll in die hose für die
organisation ich will jetzt nicht das
ist ein bisserl angegangen jetzt aus dem
was hat sie gesagt werden was unser
kamera obers leider gesagt hat dass
jetzt wenn die alle weg sind die am
flugplatz in der zentrale oder wie auch
immer das dann tat sich das tor zur
hölle öffnet das ist natürlich humbug
meine arbeit geht genauso weiter wie
bisher da kapseln die deutsche bei
meiner arbeit ich war der einzige
deutsche die ganzen projekte wurden von
afghaninnen und afghanen betrieben mit
dabei wird mit dem feld das mit den
bürgermeistern mit den taliban zusammen
warum sollte sich das jetzt ändern ich
habe alle im amt bleiben ich hoffe mal
aber nicht gebeten hat ihn zurück zug
mit dem erziehungsminister in der
provinz nangahar ist und dass bayern von
afghanistan lange als die schönste
gegend und der ist taleb italien wieder
ins amt gebracht der alte ist auch noch
da ich habe es halt lieber dort wärst du
kennst mich ich kannte ihn auch bitte
bitte macht seine arbeit weiter schickt
am montag dass die sommerferien zu ende
seine mädchen wieder auf die 30 schulen
sorgt dafür dass seine lehrerin
weiterkommen wir brauchen keine angst
haben im gegenteil jetzt ist janka hat
aber sehr viel krieg durch die
amerikaner jetzt ist kein krieg netz
fliegen morgens keine drohnen mehr jetzt
gibt es keine straßenbomben mehr als
gibt keine selbstmordattentäter mehr
schickt die bittgebete zur schule also
noch einmal dieses horror bild was
zurzeit so entsteht verständlicherweise
auch wenn wir die furchtbaren gestalten
im fernsehen sie taliban ungepflegt
hörbaren langer bart sandalen dann hat
man sich denken dass ich mein gott das
wird den möchte ich nachts nicht
begegnen in berlin aber so ist das halt
nun in gänze nicht da gibt es auch leute
mit denen man muss man reden sonst ist
das ganze projekt wirklich afghanistan
der letzten 20 jahre können wir versenkt
gut frau kann man jetzt im anschluss an
diese schädigung kann man sagen dass man
mit humanitärer hilfe jetzt in der
zukunft ein stück weit vielleicht auch
humanität in afghanistan erhalten kann
bzw
falls sie verloren gehen wieder
zurückgewinnen ich denke das ist ein
dilemma das also sagen dass er die
klassische frage
machen wird das weiter unsere
humanitären
einsätze dort unten entwicklungshilfe
und derartige dinge und stabilisieren
das regime oder gucken zu wie die kreise
klage krise immer schlimmer wird und
hoffen darauf dass irgendwann die die
afghanen sagen also ihr könnt uns ja
überhaupt nichts bieten und ihr könnt
bitte gehen das ist das dilemma also ich
würde mal sagen nachdem wenn man sich so
die die ich glaube nicht dass es geht
dass man zusieht wie das ganze land
verhungert das wird nicht gehen das kann
ich mir nicht vorstellen
ein kollege hat das mal den tanz um die
roten linien genannt und ich denke
darauf wird es hinauslaufen dass man
versucht ihnen etwas zu geben sie
brauchen ja was sie haben wir jetzt
schon gesagt nein geht doch nicht alle
fachkräfte brauchen wird doch aber man
muss auch noch dazu sagen im moment sind
ja auch noch internationale truppen im
land und die sind dann weit weg und es
klingt wunderbar was sie sagen hey ist
da fragt man sich so ein bisschen warum
die ganze angst wovor fliegen die leute
eigentlich ob das dann überall so ist
weiß man ja nie 7040 millionen also bis
nächste woche eckart lohse sind die
internationalen truppen weg wir haben
jetzt über den kontakte mit taliban
schon gesprochen die gibt es ja schon in
doha glauben sie dass die
bundesregierung da auch sagt aus
humanitären gründen werden wir weil er
diesen kontakt halten und ihn nicht ganz
abbrechen und vor allem auch die
humanitäre hilfe für afghanistan
aufrecht erhalten
also erstens hat die kanzlerin ja heute
schon gesagt was sie in den letzten
tagen so folgerichtig hat anklingen
lassen
wir werden gespräche führen scheinen uns
nicht davor
das zu tun ist findet bereits statt und
ich würde gar nicht mal sagen humanitäre
gründe sondern das sind natürlich auch
sicherheitsgründe wir wollen ja wissen
wie geht es in dem land weiter man
braucht in einem land immer
gesprächspartner jede regierung brauchen
gesprächspartner in anderen ländern
gerade wenn es so weit weg ist für uns
ist es ja eine anders als für akteure
wie russland oder china ist es ja eine
wahnsinnig weit entfernte regionen auch
auf
zusagen mental und politisch ist das
alles sehr weit von uns weg wir müssen
ja mit denen reden und dann muss man
auch sagen wir reden ja auch ansonsten
nicht nur mit lupenreinen demokraten um
ein zitat man den schröder noch einmal
aufzuwärmen wir reden auch mit saudi
arabien
nur zur erinnerung
osama bin laden kam aus saudi arabien
also wir haben ja auch andere
gesprächspartner wo wir sagen gut die
führen ein land und wir müssen jetzt
irgendwie mit denen sprechen sein ist
politische gründe sicherheitsgründe
humanitäre gründe und sein ist dass wir
das was wir dort geleistet haben wir
haben das ja eben sie ein und soll
geschildert bekommen schulen bau
mädchenbildung usw dass wir das so weit
wie möglich erhalten können und trotzdem
wissen jetzt leider an der stelle eine
wirklich nur einen einsatz machen wir da
folgt das schickt mir doch morgen an die
taliban-führung eine dvd von bob dylan
mit seinem besten song the times they
are a changing hatte geklaut vom
abitur brauchen die taliban ja auch
einen dolmetscher dafür sind
unterschiedlich
wir haben uns geeinigt auf einsatz
dieses thema geht uns ja nicht verloren
gehen ganz im gegenteil wir werden noch
häufiger mit beschäftigung besser als
uns vielleicht gibt es liebe zuschauer
morgen in der phoenix runde fluten
brennt und stürme klimapolitik auf dem
prüfstand im rahmen unseres themenabends
zu klima und umwelt im vorfeld der
bundestagswahl jetzt wirkt für nix der
tag mit thomas bade unter anderem können
sie jetzt die regierungserklärung der
bundeskanzlerin etwa in etwas längeren
passagen hören und sehen also dass bei
uns gerade mitbekommen haben ich bedanke
mich bei allen gästen hier und sie liebe
zuschauer liebe zuschauerinnen bleiben
sie bei uns